[Music]
that's a nice one i always wanted to be
a zoologist you see
that was what i've been planning for
most of my life
don't you love leopard skin print
jackets
i do
thank you
it's not important for me to be a star
you know that's not my name my name
being a household name is not something
that's important to me i want to be able
to say
that was my best we get along really
well i really do
this is my first film i've been doing
modeling for about four years
are you bit by the acting bug i mean
it's just you know yeah i guess you
could say that
you're the mask
yeah but don't tell anybody
[Music]
we first met a 21 year old cameron on
the set of jim carrey's 1994 comedy the
mask she had zero acting experience anna
nicole smith was actually the top pick
for the role of tina until producers saw
cameron's audition for another part well
i was laying in bed and i got a phone
call from my commercial agent and she
said you have to go and read for this
film and and she says it's a lead part
it's a sexy look great put on a tight
dress do up your hair look awesome you
know i'm like i don't feel like it i'm
bloated i don't feel sexy so i said well
there's a smaller part for a reporter
and i much prefer doing that i mean i've
never done a film before why would i
want to put myself in the position of a
lead
this is my first premiere so
for me anyhow yeah it's pretty exciting
my eyeballs are hurting from all the
flashes
want to stay away from stereotypes it's
very important for me to portray women
in a good way
even if it's even if it's a woman who's
very sexy and provocative i still want
women to like her
you wouldn't dare
i've come to wish you happy birthday oh
let me try this
[Music]
i've got my eye on you you've got my eye
on you
keanu busted my lip and right before we
were about to do like one of our parts
of our love scene and he busted my lip
with his shoulder and my tooth went into
it it's kind of crazy that's how the
movies are made you know totally like
that
do you feel
like an actress yet i'm absolutely
certain i'm going to be fired within the
first week i know it i i thank the
producers every day after work like
thanks i made it through
i promise i'll try harder tomorrow
[Music]
cameron says she was terrified to do
that karaoke scene in my best friend's
wedding the movie turned 25 this year
but it was this 1998 comedy that
solidified her status in hollywood as a
leading lady and earned her a golden
globe not i know it's crazy
really for me
i'm playing mary
as in there's something about
and
she's basically got four stalkers
this is the first time you've worked
with your real life love interest matt
bill and how's it been it's been great
to be able to spend the time doing it
with somebody you actually you know
enjoy and want to spend your time with
so it's good
you might give me some pointers here
yeah
don't talk in someone's backswing
is he romantic at heart i think he is
definitely
matt dillon and cameron broke up shortly
after filming the comedy she would go on
to have several high-profile romances
there was jared leto justin timberlake
diddy and a-rod dating is hard enough
it's one of those things where you just
kind of take it as it comes but one
thing that's always remained the same
cameron's unfiltered and unafraid to
tell it like it is i think that that
question is one of those questions i say
no comment about because i don't talk
about my my private life really so
pardon me for being rude but i just feel
like it's nobody's business so
do you have any other questions really
honestly this an interview about my
outfit or you have questions about the
movie
but you know we have to talk about the
fashion and over the years cameron
served up effortless style yeah i'm not
much of a gown girl
i put something on that actually is like
just putting in like on my pajamas it's
like oh that dress that's me i'll wear
that
you can't please everyone so you please
yourself you know and you just have fun
with it
you know my shoes broke on the way
literally out of the car so i'm actually
right where i want to be barefoot
walking barefoot what's better than that
in 2014 she found true love with good
charlotte's benji madden that same year
she released her last movie a remake of
annie i don't mind singing in public
like karaoke because everybody knows
that it's supposed to be like you know
you're not supposed to sing well but
trying to
sing well is not it wasn't something
that comes natural to me
and i would just like cry
i mean not on set
in in the booth when i had to like
sweaty
like dripping in sweat yeah yeah it was
pretty amazing it was a beautiful sight
after that cameron stepped away from
hollywood she officially announced her
retirement in 2018 and in 2019 secretly
welcomed daughter radix do you think
about being a mom
certainly i definitely would love to
have a family at some point so yeah now
as cameron prepares for her return
re-teaming with jamie foxx and the
netflix comedy back in action it's clear
50 is all about being fabulous and
living with no regrets
i just don't believe in staying stuck if
you're unhappy it's your responsibility
to get out of that nobody else can make
you happy not no person can do anything
for you
i love growing i love having the
experience of learning something new and
changing and becoming a different person
[Music]
you